une grange au beau milieu de la campagne
dans le nord de la touraine c'est ici
que yanek cochet a décidé d'installer
son atelier pour le sculpteur sur pierre
gouges et masse est en main le point de
départ d'un chantier est bien souvent la
réalisation d'une maquette
je travaille est en fait en tuffeau pour
un pour un édifice religieux en touraine
donc là se sont décrochés des petits
crochets gothique en fait avec des
feuillages avec que en fait c'est une
présentation qui va être faite à
l'architecte avec différents modèles
voilà donc un feuillage différents une
manière de traitement différentes aussi
comme ça l'architecte peu fera le choix
fera son choix et en fait on pourra
travailler après sur la pierre la vraie
pièce en fait voilà la maquette
permettait yanek de se rassurer avant
d'attaquer la pièce finale
elle facilite aussi le travail de
reconstitution des décors
lorsque le temps a fait de gros dégâts
sur un bâtiment comme les lucarnes
sérieusement dégradée du château de
rigny ussé il ya trois lucarne qui
disposent de ce décor et les battous les
couronnements en fait sont abîmés donc
il en manquait une grande partie donc il
manquait tout les candélabres par
exemple ces petits éléments là il
manquait ces candélabres on avait un
exemple ici donc après il a fallu les
répéter et puis à partir de la lecture
de des vestiges
on a pu interpréter en fait le décor
intégralement quoi voilà il ya juste
quelques petites quelques petits
éléments qui ont fui demande encore d un
petit peu de réflexion et c'est
l'architecte qui doivent aussi nous
apporter des solutions avant de se
lancer dans le travail de la matière il
ya neck a suivi des études d'histoire
puis d'archéologie en tant que sculpteur
il est confronté à des défis
passionnants comme par exemple la
réalisation de ce trophée dont la
maquette lui a valu le prix
départemental puis régional des métiers
d'art il s'agit du trophée du fort de la
conchée en baie de saint malo
c'est un fort qui a fort vauban qui a
été construit à quatre kilomètres au
large de saint malo pour défendre la
cité malouine des anglais des hollandais
et donc le fort a été ravagé par le
temps et par les bombardements de la
guerre la seconde guerre mondiale et
donc
une association a décidé de cesser créé
a décidé de reconstruire ce fort le
sculpteur s'attache à valoriser les
décors floraux ou statuaire d'un
bâtiment quand le tailleur de pierre
s'occupe lui tout ce qui est traçable
calculable de nombreux corps de métiers
en fait interviennent sur un chantier de
restauration sur les chantiers souvent
énormément de l'eau en fait on appelle
ça des lots en fait différents corps de
métiers des tailleurs de pierre des
restaurateurs de sculptures aussi donc
moi en tant que sculpteur je travaille
avec des tailleurs de pierre et des
restaurateurs de sculptures ou des
charpentiers aussi pour le quelquefois
on va travailler sur du bois et donc
c'est des métiers complémentaires faut
bien s'entendre il faut aussi avoir
quelques connaissances dans chaque corps
de métier ce qui est important pour pour
comprendre aussi les tenants et
aboutissants en fait un marchand tic
yanek savoure les distinctions qui
viennent régulièrement récompensé son
travail la plupart de ses clients sont
des collectivités locales est en période
de restrictions budgétaires il est
toujours bon de mettre en lumière la
restauration du patrimoine